هذا السلاح الامريكي الذي يطلق عليه جي ال
اس دي بي اختصارا لاسمها الكامل القنبله
ذات القطر الصغيره التي تطلق من الارض
سيكون من ضمن الاسلحه التي ستصل الى
اوكرانيا ضمن الحزمه الامريكيه المعلن
عنها اخيرا هذه القنبله التي ستطلق عبر
منظمه هاي مارس يصل مداها الى 150
كيلومترا اي نحو ضعف مدى صواريخ هايمارس
التي وصلت للاوكرانيين سابقا يمكن لهذه
القنابل الطيران حول التضاريس او الموانع
المصطنعه لضرب الاهداف خلف الجبال بل وحتى
وراء هدف يتمركز خلف مركبه الاطلاق نفسها
لكن رغم الحاح المسؤولين الاوكرانيين على
ضروره الاسراع في تسليم مثل هذه الاسلحه
وتحذيرهم من هجوم روسي واسع كما يقولون
فان البنتاجون ذكر ان تسليم هذه القنابل
لن يحصل قبل اشهر بسبب مواعيد الانتاج كما
لم يتضمن بيانه الاشاره الى الكميه التي
ستح عليها كيف بقيه مكونات حجمه المساعدات
العسكريه الامريكيه الاخيره المقدره
قيمتها بمليارين و 200 مليون دولار تضمنت
ايضا قذائف مدفعيه وهاون ومدافع رشاشه
ومركبات مضاده للالغام وصواريخ مضاده
للدروع ومعدات اخرى